chrissy teigen is pregnant with baby  number two lynn huh well I'm here the  model is expecting her second child with  husband John Legend  the couple who married in 2013 welcomed  their first child daughter Luna in April  2016  they were so excited yes the 31 year old  has been candid about her fertility  struggles in the past revealing that she  underwent IVF and in January Teigen  admitted to ET that her little girl  might get a baby brother a little boy is  next for sure really I mean I don't know  but we have one on ice so fingers Korea  same with the boy legend also opened up  to ET about expanding their family we  want to have more I don't know the  timing but we definitely want to have at  least a couple more  [Music]  you